kids throughout this episode we see
pretty much everyone on the streets pay
their respects to tommy through
reverential nods and courteous greetings
but this is the only time we see people
seemingly scatter from the street in
fear kind of feels like this
overreaction was more for the audience's
benefit than tommy's sir this is her the
girl who tells fortunes they're doing a
magic spell to make her win a race so
does she tell the future or influence
the future because those are two very
different spells and i think it's only
fair that tommy knows exactly what he's
paying for also cheating in case you
confused it with birmingham alabama also
we wouldn't dare play the music but
playing nick cave's red right hand in
anything other than a scream movie is a
sin this cantor's on for some time oh
look at this rube driving on the wrong
side of the road
england what does a ten-year-old know
about hell was tommy everton himself i
mean what does a ten-year-old not know
about hell being ten is hell wedgies
name-calling forced to wear winter
jackets to keep your arms in an upright
position for hours on end i'd like to
take this rare opportunity to send
decorative plates and all their futility
and the villain who created them said
villain took the humble yet functional
dinner plate and stripped it of any
purpose other than to be a prized
ornamental target for a stray baseball
that i i mean somebody might have thrown
at age 10 naturally such an occurrence
may then lead to the cancellation of a
promised trip to freaking disneyland
until i i mean they had learned the true
value of [ __ ] decorative plates tv
show expects us to believe that a house
in 1919 has some of the best
soundproofing known to humanity in the
form of these two wooden doors that are
apparently able to block out all of this
hustle and bustle also are these
curtains supposed to be hiding these
doors i say old boy i can certainly hear
a mighty din coming from somewhere but
my goalie these curtains have me rather
vexed as to its origin also also if the
piggy blinders make such a fuss to cover
the entrance to their den of iniquities
then why wouldn't tommy have enough
sense to close the door behind him
chalkboard beer loose change excitement
[Music]
ah sudden alan grant i hate it when a tv
show makes me work for my exposition
couldn't we have been shown all this
information through a conveniently timed
news report or a suspiciously specific
flashback and admittedly we would have
send either of those but at least i
wouldn't have to do all this reading
also if this file is top secret then why
would it give away the topic of the
contents on the cover it could just say
for inspector campbell's eyes only also
also this episode takes place in 1919
and this rap sheet has the term
racketeering on it which is for one an
american phrase and for two was not
coined until 1925. this is a rap sheet
of lies we're here today to take a vote
on strike action no one will be seated
for the hot sweaty strike action all
those who stood side by side with your
comrades and watched your comrades fall
i swear freddy says comrades 16 times in
five minutes just in case we confused
him for a fascist raise ahead all those
who want to strike
if the point of this meeting was to vote
on whether or not to take strike action
this meeting was entirely pointless
judging by these cheers it doesn't seem
like there was anyone on the fence or
even close to voting against it this
feels like another one of those scenes
made exclusively to exposit all over me
and i hate being exposited over without
consent crown of a prince holy [ __ ] are
there razor blades in there then why the
[ __ ] did he tap pour finn here on the
head like this i guess
you're home we're all home in england
you're not
i'm not saying the show gets everything
right but it does go out of its way to
highlight how poorly returning service
people were cared for both mentally and
physically by the government that sent
them to war in the first place a lesson
unfortunately we still can't seem to
learn today bring the bill to the peaky
blinders gamble commercials how did and
polly know that he was going to take
this exact route at this exact time how
long has she been waiting here has she
been pulling this gun on random people
until she found her man also no one
seems to care about this woman holding a
man at gunpoint in the middle of the
[ __ ] day on what looks like a
relatively busy street if you're over
five feet and can fight come to
birmingham that's heightest and pacifist
ist i say catholic man who crossed them
used to disappear in the night yeah but
we ain't ira
we bloody fought for the king do that as
it may you're still doing some pretty
sketchy stuff that the police have every
right to be investigating hey i'm just
saying don't cap me or anything you have
nothing more to say to this meeting
thomas no
nothing that's women's business that's
sexist and you're seriously pulling this
[ __ ] with aunt paulie did no one show
him the alleyway scene can we rewind
that for him inside we found 25 lewis
machine guns
10 000 rounds of ammunition
50 semi-automatic rifles 200 pistols
with shells as much as tommy's tipsy
tearaways can be blamed for stealing
this [ __ ] a good portion of the blame
has to be laid at the feet of the morons
who decided to leave this unspeakable
amount of weaponry in such an unguarded
and highly vulnerable position to be
stolen in the first place by and i
repeat a group of inebriated imbeciles
also i guess these are now tommy guns
dump them somewhere the police can find
them where exactly would that be then i
can't think of anywhere tommy could dump
the guns that would guarantee the police
finding them first except a police
station of course and that's clearly too
risky any road what they should do is
dump them somewhere and then anonymously
tip the police off to their location
tommy and paula are acting like they've
never accidentally stolen a shipment of
guns before and
charlie to dump it
tonight no he won't move contraband
under the full moon i'd give all the
sins back if we discovered the rival
gang was a group of werewolves i got
tickets for the penny crush the showing
of thomas picture deep cut by the cut
soon we'll tell when how did the family
meet and go answering a question with a
question grace has one shot to impress
the landlord and she chooses this bullsh
cackhanded method to empty the pots why
even pick up the bigger bucket leave the
damn thing on the ground and pour the
smaller pots into them using both hands
thus minimizing the amount of spittle on
skin seepage in ireland
my singing made them cry and stopped
from fighting well yeah if you know a
lot of songs why does any of this
convince him not one of his original
concerns has been addressed this was
never about her ability or vocal talent
but the fact that she is too pretty and
will be abused by the customers but of
course none of that matters because the
plot needs her to get the job so get the
job she shall the vicious
merciless gongs
who blind those at sea come now you
can't really judge them for that
blinding those that don't see would be
rather counterproductive and like
maggots have left to swell they will
eventually swarm like flies and spread
their rotten philosophy
across the country my goodness it's as
if campbell used a random simile
generator took all of the suggestions
shoved them in a metaphysical blender
and then put pen to paper to write this
speech and what i need to know is how
did he discover my method also what the
hell that didn't even look like sam neil
he is unfucking recognizable in this
role both in presentation and voice he's
intimidating masterful and i love it
talk irish to me sammy and that takes
some ironing
wow this was a suspiciously well-timed
entrance did campbell rehearse this
little production
when you're out with a blinder
you don't have to kill but the british
love queuing how very unpatriotic of you
sir for shame
copper blocking during campbell's speech
he made it very clear that one of his
goals was to stamp out police corruption
nice to see him leading by example here
with the good old clinched fist to the
nose method of policing have you ever
gone no i've gone
no i finished suck caution his belt
maybe he was just happy to see you are
you a [ __ ] because if you're not in the
wrong place tommy survives this look
grace you defend the girl but be careful
if i say something's on the house then
say nothing to whoever you're serving to
be fair grace didn't say anything other
than
tommy then immediately volunteered the
slur that followed i suppose if anything
it's a nice reminder that we as a
society have moved on from this kind of
victim shaming
you know what he'd do if he found out
about us he could try but earlier he
said oh i'm scared of them all right so
which one is it or does his attitude
towards his brummie bait noir change
depending on what the scene requires for
dramatic effect because it really
shouldn't i say go home crazy man
[Music]
i said go home
in what way is approaching the clearly
unstable danny with a knife the best
course of action this seems like a very
close-knit community and judging by the
reactions to his earlier episode danny's
understandable mental instability seems
to be fairly well known at the very
least this gentleman should know that
danny is associated with the peaky
blinders so was he really intending on
stabbing danny and incurring their wrath
there is more train porn in this episode
than the entirety of murder on the
orient express and you might ask which
version i'm referring to and of course
i'm referring to the best one you know
the one that stars alfred molina
by the way hat fetishes
it's beaver title of my sex tape i want
everything accounted for
down to the last bullet if you wanted
them accounted for perhaps you shouldn't
have made them so damn easy to steal in
the first place you just won a world war
and you've been foiled by three drunken
brummies who weren't even trying to
steal them are you in possession i am
sir despite their admirable attempt at
subterfuge this is still a very public
place to meet especially considering
they have suspiciously arrived in town
on the same day and embedded themselves
rather deeply into the criminal
underbelly albeit in different forms
made all the more cynical by the fact
that grace gives up any pretense that
she isn't talking to campbell after less
than two minutes
as you know the man you killed was
italian those two men over there not his
brothers well stone the crows wasn't
that a coincidence told me wanted you to
think it was real
try to knock some sense into you a shell
full of sheep brains so it's pretty bad
it may well be the permanent alternative
but this was an astonishingly cruel
thing to do to a man that is already
suffering from acute ptsd now i'm not
expecting this to be necessarily taken
into account in 1919 but damn it tommy
hasn't the man got enough keeping him up
at night without adding another
near-death experience
i'm fine i just uh
threw up in my mouth a little bit you
eat me you tell them i'm coming and
hell's coming with me you
by exploiting the workers by hanging on
to outdated imperialist dogma which
perpetuates the economic and social
differences in our society if there's
ever going to be any progress there's
some lovely filth down here and the very
same goes for ezekiel
which brings us back to our starting
point
the nine tenets of constancy
[Music]
a day of redemption is at hand
repent
and thou shall be saved
what happened to your eyes
where we're going
we won't need eyes to say